this first one comes from Paul Bren
sholde only speaking appalled the jersey
do you see that this is my Jersey it's
me and Ralph done his peanuts character
yeah look at you you're like a real
bitter Schroeder you got a big [ __ ]
drink in here yeah that's the way I like
it
Paul Quinn did this man and you look
like like Charlie with a beard yeah
Charlie Brown that's but but they've had
this for a little bit but then I had a
mad had him at you very cool totally I
it's count you look like a male Lucy
really and ready to pull that football
away yeah a speaking of your jerseys
yeah this has to do with that old from
Paul Brent schuld who is an actual
hockey goalie and he said following the
news of Kevin's heart attack I decided
to for my game the following night to
break out my Kevin Jersey in honor of
Kevin flipping the bird to the Grim
Reaper I thought Kevin might like what
to see what it looks like when his
jerseys actually worn on the ice without
jorts so here's Paul on the ice in the
net where the Jersey and that's what it
looks like when an actual hockey players
wearing one of your hockey jersey yeah
that's what I look like and I'm not
athletic I got that much padding that is
how Canada pays tribute to Kevin now
let's see how Canada pays tribute to me
shall we the same from Joe in Vancouver
BC Canada Kevin and I announced we were
doing a little bit of a Canadian tour
we're going to go up to Canada later on
this year we're going to performing in
Calgary and Edmonton and Vancouver and
tickets went on sale in Vancouver and
all the tickets were mailed out to the
kind of folks who were good enough to
buy tickets for that show at the
Commodore Ballroom and the tickets were
mailed out and Joe said I might want to
take a look at the tickets that they
sent out Thanks Ticketmaster Canada
Hollywood babble-on with Kevin Smith and
the multi-talented Ryan Garmin
everybody's gonna be there so in Canada
they wear his Jersey and tribute they
can't be bothered to spell my [ __ ]
name correctly apparently up there so
really
Canada really I mean once and for all
let's just go up there and take that
[ __ ] country and just come on let's
build the wall whatever it takes
whatever let's go let's use this lunatic
we have in charge for something good and
finally just take over that kid that
cult that whole bunch of people up there
take it easy Ryan right
[Music]
you
[Music]